For the most part, we're going to focus on normally distributed data. There are
many kinds of normal distributions. Stretched, skinny, or maybe somewhere in the
middle. But the area underneath will always be 1, or 100%. You've also seen
before that in a normally distributed data set, the mean, median, and mode are
approximately equal. In our theoretical model, they're exactly equal. Our
theoretical model is perfectly symmetrical. This doesn't usually happen in real
life. These models approximate our real distributions. But we can usually get
pretty good approximations. And in our theoretical model, most of the data is in
the middle clustered around the mean, median and mode. You might recall from the
last lesson that approximately 68% lie within one standard deviation of the
mean. And 95% fall within 2 standard deviations of the mean.